este es el campo de karate construido
para albergar a los demandantes de asilo
que quedaron en la calle tras el
incendio de moria
antes aquí había arbustos imagínense no
había prácticamente nada spyros trabaja
para el gobierno conservador griego y es
uno de los responsables del campo el
recinto fue levantado en algunos días
por el ejército con ayuda de la unión
europea y naciones unidas
hay incluso una zona de cuarentena para
los contagiados de kobe 19 en karate p
los ocupantes reciben el agua con
camiones cisterna los baños son químicos
y solo tienen electricidad algunas horas
al día
con cola hoy tenemos una situación mucho
más controlada y organizada que la que
teníamos en moria que nació durante la
crisis migratoria de 2015 no vamos a
construir un segundo moria eso no
volverá a pasar nuestra estrategia
consiste en reubicar los en cuanto sea
posible colocar y desde que sea posible
en la puerta de acceso los controles han
sido endurecidos sólo mil migrantes
pueden salir cada día gracias a un
número que deben devolver al regresar
por la noche armas alcohol y productos
inflamables están prohibidos para evitar
que se repitan los problemas de memoria
hay gente que está enferma no están bien
atendidos los servicios higiénicos están
sucios la gente duerme en el suelo yo
prefiero estar en moore ya que aquí
tenemos miedo de los hombres solteros es
muy difícil estar aquí siendo mujer sola
mi sueño a salir de esta isla incluso
para volver a siria quiero irme de aquí
queremos irnos de esta isla es nuestro
sueño hace un año y 15 días que salimos
de siria
el gobierno griego ha prometido evacuar
todos los migrantes de moría de aquí a
la semana santa del próximo año de hecho
una parte ya ha sido instalada en la
grecia continental para
atenas confía en el apoyo de la unión
europea ya sea para recibir migrantes o
bien pagar para enviarlos de regreso a
sus países de origen
[Música]